now there's a new National Geographic
Channel film that may have solved the
secrets of Stonehenge yeah if you've
done the kind of research I've done then
you know the truth reverberation
experiments are done here mm-hmm notices
a certain vibration levels the dirt will
change
[Music]
yeah
that's it that's what it does you see
does what the change is this yeah this
wasn't what it looks like now a week ago
the reverberations the harmonics change
it organically well what what did it
look like before it was marinara sauce a
week ago I wasn't dirt no it was orange
and quite tasty yeah so that's the
miracle of science you're saying what's
this have to do with Stonehenge
everything well how does it have a sign
no no no I'm getting impatient because
you don't seem to really be connecting
all the dots do you if you took this
guitar in the amplifier to Stonehenge in
you plugged it in and you're saying it's
a rock no it's not a rock it was an
amplifier originally and I plugged it in
I'm sorry
Stonehenge was an amplifier originally
of course it's not a fire for who
exactly